Hi guys, and welcome to my channel.
Today I wanted to talk about
how to make the home amazing.
Being a traditional wife
is so much more than just cooking and cleaning
and wearing house dresses.
It is taking your house and making it a home.
And not only that,
but making your home
the most enjoyable place you possibly can
for yourself,
for your family.
That's part of being a traditional wife.
We wives budget down hard.
I think that is the most
realistic part about being a traditional wife
is that it's not all glamorous
all the time.
There is times where you don't get what you want,
and that's okay.
So instead of always spending all this crazy money
at a coffee shop.
I used to do that, by the way.
I used to do that.
We make our coffee at home
for the most part.
That doesn't mean we don't go out to a coffee shop,
like, ever. My husband took me out for my birthday
to the mountains.
And you know what?
I did get a coffee.
And it was expensive
because it was my birthday.
We were celebrating.
My husband wanted to treat me,
but most of the time
I make this bad girl at home.
And that is okay.
Another thing traditional wives love is aprons.
Cause these aprons are like our house uniforms.
We know when we put this aprons on,
we Mean Business.
We are gonna get to cooking.
We are Gonna get to cleaning.
We are going to scrub this house down.
It's so we can wear our beautiful clothes in our home
and still protect them with an apron.
And you can have such lovely aprons.
You can have a whole collection.
And it just makes getting ready for the day
and putting that thing on, like,
so much fun.
Traditional wives love dressing up for their husbands
even though they are staying at home.
And why is that?
Because there's just so much to celebrate
about being a wife.
We are at home so much.
Why would we only dress up just to leave the house
when we are gonna be around other people?
Why wouldn't we dress up
to see the most important person of our life,
which is our husband?
Duh. So we enjoy our time
getting ready
and being really girly girls
and putting on the cute dresses,
doing our hair,
doing our makeup.
And of course,
every woman's routine is different.
I'm not saying that this is the same for every woman,
but we celebrate
being at home
and we celebrate being wives.
Big part of making the most at our home is
really taking the things that we would probably do out,
like getting our nails done constantly,
getting facials
and stuff like that.
And we try and learn them at home.
This is part of budgeting.
It's saying yes to some things
and saying no to others
and learning to do them
At home or yourself somehow?
So for me personally,
I do get my hair highlighted,
but I try and do my nails at home.
I don't have my nails done right now.
I actually just took it off
because I'm going to paint my nails after this video.
But I have Learned to do that at home
because it's something that I started doing recently
that has just.
It's made me feel so put together,
just like looking down and seeing my nails done.
But I don't wanna spend that kind of money
every two to three weeks
to get my nails professionally done
when I can just learn it at home.
So, you see, there's a give,
there's a take,
and that is a big part of being a traditional wife.
And there's sacrifice with every life.
So if you are a career woman,
you are sacrificing time at home
for your career.
And same with traditional wives.
We are sacrificing a career
for more time at home.
But that might mean we have less materialistic things
and we are not able to go on fancy vacations as much.
That is okay.
For example,
my husband and I had a humble honeymoon. Yes,
you heard that right.
Humble honeymoon.
That means we did not go
to a different country and spend
thousands and thousands of dollars on our honeymoon.
We actually got the gift to spend the week at, um,
my. My husband's uncle's house
in Myrtle Beach.
And we Went there,
and we spent money on excursions
and delicious food.
But that is considered a humble honeymoon.
We drove, what,
four hours away from our house? And, um,
it was beautiful.
It was budget friendly,
but we had so much fun.
Because it's not about
the crazy honeymoon,
the expensive stuff.
It is about
just getting married
and celebrating the fact that you got married
and a little trip for just you and your husband.
And so, yeah,
I am all for humble honeymoon.
So, as you guys can see,
being a traditional wife
is making the most of your home situation,
taking a home
and making it a sanctuary
for both you and your family.
And I hope this inspires you guys
to do something that you love
outside of your home
and take the time to learn it
in your home,
because it can make such a big difference
and you learn a new skill. Bye.